El 1 de julio de 1997, tras 155 años de soberanía
británica, Hong Kong volvió a formar parte
de China. Lo hizo como una región administrativa
especial, bajo el modelo un país, dos sistemas.
Un modelo, amigos, que tenía como objetivo
garantizar que Hong Kong siguiese siendo Hong
Kong, la ciudad más libre de todo el continente
asiático.
Es decir, gracias a esta particular configuración
política, Hong Kong tiene su propias leyes,
su propia justicia, su propia policía, su
moneda e, incluso, la política de aduanas
e inmigración es diferente a la del resto
de China.
Vamos que de facto, en el día a día, funciona
casi como un país independiente. Y seguirá
siendo así hasta por lo menos el año 2047.
Tal vez por ello, desde que Hong Kong pasó
a manos chinas, las cosas a la ciudad no le
han ido del todo mal.
(Durante este tiempo, la economía de Hong
Kong ha crecido de media un 3,3% anual; más
de 1 millón de personas procedentes de la
China continental se han trasladado a este
territorio en busca de fortuna; y la ciudad
sigue siendo un oasis de libertad)
Eso sí, la influencia y la intromisión del
gobierno chino en la política local ha crecido
mucho en los últimos años.
Aquí, en VisualPolitik ya os hemos hablado
de todo esto. Por ejemplo, en pasados vídeos
hemos hablado ya sobre la revolución de los
paraguas o sobre la creciente injerencia de
Pekín en la política local.
Pues bien, amigos, en este vídeo vamos a
comentar otra de las características más
destacadas de este lugar.
¿Sabíais que Hong Kong es la ciudad con
las casas más pequeñas y caras del mundo?
Atentos.
UN MERCADO POR LAS NUBES
Con siete millones y medio de habitantes y
más de 1200 rascacielos, las casas en Hong
Kong son terriblemente caras.
[Bueno, las casas, las garajes, las oficinas…
todo lo que tenga que ver con el sector inmobiliario
es… carísimo. Tanto que podemos encontrar
noticias como está:]
(“Vendida en Hong Kong por 600.000 euros
la plaza de garaje más cara del mundo”
De hecho, amigos, si tuvierais 1 millón de
dólares, de dólares estadounidenses, y quisierais
compraros… digamos, un apartamento en una
de las zonas buenas de la ciudad, apenas podréis
compraros, atentos, 22m2 ¡por un millón
de dólares!
Tal cual como lo escucháis. Es una cifra
que asusta.
Hong Kong es considerada como la segunda ciudad
de todo el mundo donde las viviendas premium
son más caras, tan solo por detrás de Mónaco.
(“El fundador de Alibaba, Jack Ma, compra
en Hong Kong la segunda casa más cara del
mundo por metro cuadrado. Ha pagado 175 millones
de euros por una casa de 920m2” Idealista.)
Pero claro, si tenemos en cuenta que en Hong
Kong vive todo tipo de gente y exceptuamos
el caso tan particular de Mónaco, Hong Kong
es con diferencia la ciudad con las casas
más caras de todo el mundo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde 2003 el
precio de la vivienda en Hong Kong ha crecido
un 450% y hoy el precio medio del m2 supera
los 16.000 dólares norteamericanos.
[Sí, esto quiere decir que si os queréis
comprar una cosa normalita, nada de lujos,
de 90m2 vais a tener que pagar, ojo, por lo
menos, un millón y medio de dólares. ¡Pedazo
de hipoteca!]
Mirad, es muy habitual para comparar qué
ciudades son más o menos accesibles, utilizar
los años de salarios medios, antes de pagar
impuestos, que necesitamos para comprar la
vivienda media que se vende. Pues bien, atentos,
(Según los últimos datos publicados, para
comprar una casa en Hong Kong necesitaremos
algo más de 18 años de salarios íntegros.
Por comparar, en ciudades como Tokyo o Singapur
se necesitan menos de 5 años de salarios)
Es decir, lo de Hong Kong es una locura.
Y no solo eso, como las casas son tan caras
y tan inaccesibles para los propios ciudadanos
de Hong Kong… pues estos han tenido que
ir comprando cada vez casas más pequeñas.
¿Sabéis qué superficie tiene una casa media
en Hong Kong? Venga mojaros, ¿100 m2?¿80?¿60?
¡Qué va! ¡42m2!
[¿Os imagináis viviendo en una casa de 42m2?
Pues, atentos a la última moda:]
(“Hong Kong es tan caro que los arquitectos
están construyendo «casas-tubería» de
10 metros cuadrados hechas con tuberías de
hormigón” Foro Económico Mundial.)
Pero, vale, puede que alguno de vosotros esté
pensando… wow, Enrique, es muy poco pero...
seguro que es porque muchas personas viven
sola en diminutos apartamentos que alteran
las estadísticas, ¿Verdad?
Pues… amigos, nada de eso… De media viven
casi 3 personas en un apartamento de 42m2
¡Menuda locura!
Y, ojo, no solo son las casas. Ocurre exactamente
lo mismo con las oficinas:
(“Vendida una torre de 346 metros en Hong
Kong por 4.419 millones de euros, récord
mundial”)
Pero claro, dicho todo esto, hay una pregunta
que seguro que os estais haciendo ¿por qué
diantres son tan caras las casas en Hong Kong?
Pues… atentos.
¿EL MITO DE  LA FALTA DE TIERRA?
Espacios masificados, rascacielos por todas
partes, pisos pequeños… que digo pequeños…
diminutos y carísimos… aparentemente, así
es como todos podríamos describir a Hong
Kong, ¿no os parece?
Al fin y al cabo estamos hablando de uno de
los lugares con mayor densidad de población
de todo el mundo.
Y viendo lo que hemos visto sobre los precios
y los tamaños de la vivienda… blanco y
en botella:
mucha gente y poco espacio parece la combinación
perfecta para que los precios sean tan altos
¿Verdad?
Pues… esperad un momento, porque decir esto,
amigos... no es contar toda la verdad.
(Lo cierto es que menos del 25%, de una cuarta
parte, del territorio de Hong Kong está urbanizado
y apenas el 7% de todo el territorio está
ocupado por viviendas urbanas.
Fuera de las zonas más masificadas podemos
encontrar campo, selva, aldeas antiguas, campos
de golf y muchas, muchísimas viviendas unifamiliares.)
Un momento, ¿Cómo es esto posible?
Pues veréis, durante años ha sido considerada
por el Índice de Libertad Económica como
la economía más libre de todo el planeta.
Es decir, hablamos de un lugar con impuestos
bajos, comercio libre, seguridad jurídica
y una intervención del gobierno muy pequeña.
Vamos, lo que viene siendo una ciudad muy
capitalista. Por algo es el tercer mayor centro
financiero del mundo, tras Londres y Nueva
York.
[Por cierto, como curiosidad. La Ley Básica,
la constitución de Hong Kong, limita que
el gobierno pueda gastar más de lo que ingresa.
Esto ha hecho que el gobierno suela cerrar
todos los años con superávits, es decir
gastando menos de lo que ingresa. Superávits
que ha ido acumulando para lograr tener unos
ahorros, ojo, de más de 220.000 millones
de dólares. Sí, aquí todo eso de la deuda
pública no les hace mucha gracia]
Pero… sigamos. El caso es que a pesar de
tanta libertad y tanta apuesta por el capitalismo…
lo cierto es que hay un sector muy pero que
muy intervenido por el gobierno.
¿Sabéis cuál es? Pues… precisamente,
el sector inmobiliario.
Veréis, en Hong Kong, prácticamente toda
la tierra es propiedad del gobierno.
(Las autoridades públicas controlan cuándo
y cuánta tierra se pone en el mercado para
poder construir. Por supuesto, el Departamento
de Vivienda, Planificación y Tierra también
decide qué es lo que se va a poder construir.
Generalmente la concesión de tierra se realiza
mediante subastas, cuando se trata de viviendas
privadas, oficinas o usos comerciales; o directamente
mediante acuerdos con promotores cuando se
va a construir vivienda pública con alquileres
más “económicos”, que es donde vive
una gran parte de la población)
Por cierto, lo normal, incluso en las subastas,
es que la propiedad siga siendo del gobierno,
lo que se conceden es un derecho de uso por
X años.
Pues bien, que las casas sean tan caras en
Hong Kong tiene mucho que ver con la escasez,
pero no con una escasez geográfica sino con
una decidida por el gobierno.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Terreno hay más que de sobra para desarrollar
nuevas áreas residenciales y de oficinas.
Y, además, siempre está la opción de ganar
terreno en el mar.
Sí, no es nada extraño: una cuarta parte
de todas las áreas edificadas de Hong Kong
se asientan sobre terrenos que fueron ganados
al mar.
Pero todo, absolutamente, tiene que ser decidido
por el gobierno.
(“La escasez de tierra es un mito. Hay más
de 200 hectáreas de terreno disponibles para
construir en las zonas urbanas. La escasez
de viviendas es real, pero eso se debe a la
manipulación deliberada del mercado por el
gobierno.” John Wright)
Pues bien, en las últimas décadas, como
hemos dicho antes, la población de Hong Kong
ha crecido bastante porque han llegado muchas
personas de China; además el tamaño de la
familia se ha reducido y muchos inversores
chinos quieren invertir en esta ciudad conocida
por su seguridad jurídica.
Todo esto ha hecho, amigos, que la demanda
se dispare… algo que no ha ocurrido con
la oferta… porque el gobierno no ha querido.
("Los precios de las casas crecerán aún
más debido al escaso suministro", Thomas
Lam, jefe de valoración y consultoría de
Knight Frank.)
Pero… ¿Qué interés tiene el gobierno
en restringir la oferta y hacer crecer los
precios? Pues… hay al menos 2 motivos:
El primero es que las subastas son todo un
negocio para las arcas públicas. En 2017,
por ejemplo, 1 de cada 5 dólares en ingresos
públicos procedieron de la venta de suelo.
Hablamos de más de 15.000 millones de dólares.
El segundo motivo… y mucho más siniestro,
es que hay sospechas de relaciones no muy
limpias [corrupción] entre las autoridades
y los grandes promotores.
Veréis, el sector inmobiliario en Hong Kong
está muy concentrado en pocas manos… manos
que son multimillonarias.
Y digamos que estos grandes empresarios prefieren
mantener por las nubes los precios y evitar
la competencia… algo que sucede cuando el
gobierno saca al mercado poco suelo y, además.
incrementa la burocracia para cualquier nuevo
proyecto.
Así, las pequeñas y medianas empresas no
pueden entrar… y las extranjeras tampoco
se atreven, porque parten en clara desventaja.
Por supuesto, amigos, todo esto tiene consecuencias.
Atentos.
LAS CONSECUENCIAS.
El disparatado precio de las viviendas ha
hecho que a pesar de haber mucho empleo y
salarios altos, muchas personas vivan en condiciones
difíciles, como es para una familia tener
en 40m2 pagando unas hipotecas desorbitadas.
Además, este sistema ha hecho a muchas personas,
especialmente los más jóvenes, sean dependientes
del gobierno, dependientes de los alquileres
en viviendas públicas… que por supuesto
también son casas muy pequeñas.
[Pensad, que en Hong Kong, además, no cabe
la posibilidad de irse a vivir al extrarradio
o a zonas más alejadas porque eso supondría
cruzar a la China continental… y perder
todas las libertades que las personas tienen
en esta ciudad.]
(Y, por si fuera poco, el alto precio de las
oficinas y naves empresariales ha hecho que
muchas empresas y muchas inversiones acaben
en otras ciudades del Delta de Río de las
Perlas, como Shenzhen, lo que plantea problemas
de futuro.)
Pero de todo eso hablaremos otro día.
En fin, amigos, así están las cosas en la
ciudad que hasta ahora ha sido uno de los
faros más destacados de prosperidad y libertad
en Asia. El futuro nos dirá qué ocurre,
y ¿sabéis qué? En VisualPolitik estaremos
muy atentos.
Pero ahora, turno para ti. ¿Crees que las
autoridades de Hong Kong deben promover el
crecimiento de la ciudad incrementando la
oferta inmobiliaria? Déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte al canal si
aún no lo has hecho.
Ahora sí, un saludo y hasta la próxima.